the fastest way to absorb news is a
revolutionary app called newsreels i use
it all the time to quickly catch up on
news by scrolling through the reels page
similar to an instagram feed you can
read any story as quickly summarized
bullet points click the link below to
use newsreels for free
let's go next to alex from baltimore
maryland alex you're on the air
hey david can you hear me i can
hey great so i have a question about
moderates in general so i feel like a
popular
take from the left is that anyone who
has a moderate even if it's a liberal
viewpoint is therefore corrupt and
therefore a shill
do you believe that to be true and how
do you tell the difference between the
two no um so you you know that thing
about like you can you know porn when
you see it um i think people know
grifter and enlightened centrist
positions when they see them versus
someone who's just moderate i think
there's a difference between
staking out positions of neutrality to
be
perceived as some kind of you know above
the fray centrist and it's often very
disingenuous and very transparent versus
there are issues on which people can
just genuinely be moderate and it
doesn't mean they've sold out to anyone
there could be you know think about
taxation there are people who might
think that the top tax rate should be 90
percent and some who think there should
be no taxes or a 5 flat tax and you're
going to come come across someone who
just thinks hey like i don't know it
should be 42 a little bit higher than we
have now but that's it
just because they're at 42 and someone
else is at 37 and someone else is at 20
there's no particular reason to say if
you end up in the middle you're you've
it's because of a corrupting influence
there's there's no substantive basis to
believe that uh that's different than
people who just sort of uh frame
themselves as
neutral and centrist on everything to
pretend to be above bias you understand
the distinction i'm making
yeah i do again and and that's kind of
how i feel i just it's just actually my
comment was more about the commentary of
how other
progress oh yeah yeah yeah assume that
because you're a moderate yep
you are therefore you are corrupt no i
think i think that that's wrong yeah you
believe no i don't believe it either and
i guess that's my point there's no
there's no there's no substantive reason
to assume that because someone is
moderate on an issue
their view is corrupted by whatever no i
disagree with people who think that
whether they're on the left or right
fair enough and i do have a i have a
quick travel question for you because
you again i i call it a little bit a
while ago about
uh travel stuff um i have young kids
where would you recommend the foreign
country that is more kid-friendly oh my
goodness i have no idea what does it
mean kid friendly i mean there's
millions of children in countries all
over the world
that is true i guess my thinking on that
would be is you know things that we as
adults that to explore other countries
would be fun would not be fun for a
six-year-old right you know i guess
other places where they would have
things for kids as well and not just you
know
old cultural stuff that you and i would
find interesting but yeah a six year
eight-year-old would i have no idea what
a six or eight year old finds
interesting to be perfectly frank i i'm
so poorly positioned to answer the
question
no that's fair it was just more of a fun
question to ask you and i have one last
quickie food debate sure um it is autumn
fall whatever you prefer to call it sure
um
pumpkin spice or apple cider flavor
oh my god i don't do either but i will
have an occasional um cider donuts so i
guess i'd go cider cider flavor rather
than than pumpkin spice
uh it is a that's a fair point i
thoroughly enjoy both but i figured that
was you know you're from the northeast i
figured that'd be a big question for you
yeah yeah no the pumpkin spice stuff i'm
seeing everybody with their pumpkin
spice lattes that are half whipped cream
with it's just it should be illegal
that's my view i don't know i i i i turn
into a very basic white girl this time
of year so
all right my friend on that one thank
you very much for the call likewise yeah
thanks very much yeah no by the way i
don't think pumpkin spice should be
illegal i just you know it's not for me
i guess is the point that i'm trying to
make